I have something that I think you're going
to enjoy today.
There is a young woman named Caitlin Bennett
who I had never heard of before yesterday
before seeing the videos I'm going to play
for you today, but apparently she's known
as gun girl in some circles.
She's a pro gun anti-abortion, anti trans,
seemingly religious conservative.
She strikes me as a religious conservative,
although, although maybe that's not the case.
Wikipedia says that Bennett received media
attention in 2018 because she opened, carried
an AR 10 rifle at Kent state university.
Imagine being known for holding a gun, holding
a gun is what she's known for.
I believe she's 2324 years old.
She goes to college campuses and she does
these horribly bad faith, dishonest, gotcha
type interviews where she wants to show how
crazy things are on liberal college campuses
and she asks students, what do you think about
abortion or what do you think about guns or
trans people?
It's done totally out of context and very
bad faith.
And she did this the other day and a young
man who has upper management written all over
him.
I think you will agree.
After watching this segment stopped her short
when she started asking, Oh, what about tampons
and men's rooms or what about this or that?
And the kid very clearly says, who cares?
No one's committing a crime.
I'm living my life.
I believe in individual Liberty.
Who cares about this stuff?
Check this out.
What do you think about putting urinals and
women's restrooms for women who have penises
and they just want to stand in pee?
I think people just making too big of a deal
about it.
I don't really care naughty words.
Okay, so we showed her shouldn't, I mean I
really care.
Okay.
What about tampons and pads and men's restroom
for men who have periods, if you're really
getting that worked up about it, why does
it matter?
Like I don't care just sitting there.
I'm not going to take it.
Okay, so we should provide men with tampons.
I mean, if a dude wants a tampon for some
reason he can have a tampon.
That's not my business.
What would he use it for?
I don't know.
That's his problem.
Well, we use a pad for his problem.
Do you think they should seek medical advice
if they're having bleeding?
I mean, if they want to.
I don't really care.
Why should I here?
I don't know.
I care about people that they're bleeding
out of their penis.
I would want to, I care about people's personal
rights.
They can do whatever they want.
Some, none of my business.
Beautifully done.
Absolutely beautifully done.
This is like a fake, reactionary libertarian.
This woman, Katelyn Bennett meeting an actual
libertarian and I mean libertarian in the
authoritarian versus libertarian sense, not
like a capital L libertarian who says there's
no crime being committed.
There's no violence to anyone.
There's no interference with my life.
What do I care about where a tampon is found?
She has nowhere to go with it because she
can't get an emotional response from the student.
So she has to become more unhinged and start
saying things like, what about a bleeding
penis?
Then here's another one that went horribly
wrong and she actually is so unbearable that
I almost started feeling bad for how dumb
she looked here.
But then I didn't take a look at this.
Yeah, there's, there's a, there's more than
people think.
White men having periods.
Yeah, I got did you tell them to seek clinical
help if men are having periods?
Well, trans men have periods.
Okay.
Explain that one to me.
Yeah.
So some people who have transitioned from
female to male, um, you know, obviously, you
know, they might still have periods and you
know, if they identify as male, you know,
they have the right to go into the men's room.
Uh, but if they're still having periods, they
have the right to have, you know, the products
they need.
This
is of course how these reactionary social
conservative movements work.
They work by strategically narrowly framing
questions when it makes sense.
And then when it's more convenient, you broaden
it where the questions and the topic are way
too broad to actually have any meaning and
it conservative, I'm sorry, conspiracy theorists
actually do the same thing.
There's a strategy in pushing conspiracy theories
where you will sometimes say, let's zoom way
out in order to further your conspiracy theory.
But when taking a broad view actually hurts
your, you're a conspiracy theory.
You zoom way in into narrowly, uh, calculated
details.
And it's a very similar strategy here.
First they go very broad.
Something like the identity politics left
things men can have periods.
Okay, well, it's not hard to understand.
If you're born biologically female, you transitioned
to male.
Unless you have certain procedures, you've
got a uterus, you have the reproductive system,
it doesn't go away.
So someone who identifies as male in society
and uses the men's room might still have a
period.
Menstruation may still be part of their biological
reality.
So then they go broad and they right, the
left thinks men has period, have periods or
something like that.
And then when you point out how absurd the
framing is, they will narrow it to, are you
telling me you don't care about someone who's
penis is bleeding?
This isn't about a man whose penis is bleeding.
This is about individual Liberty.
It's about rights.
It's about nobody's breaking any laws.
And the most important takeaway here, because
it's an election year, is that these people
vote.
And many people agree with the framing of
a cake.
Katelyn, Katelyn Bennett, she gets to vote.
The people who find her intelligent and who
find her videos prescient about the future
of America, they vote.
And none of this means anything.
If we can't start fixing this problem
from the bottom up and that means we all have
to vote in November of 2020 I want to hear
from you, what do you think about these videos?
We'll take a quick break and be back right
after this,